bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission grands reportages
handicapés grande cause européenne
presque deux européens sur dix souffrent
d'un handicap et les gouvernements
européens se sont donné un objectif
d'ici six mois les trois quarts des
handicapés pourront accéder à un emploi
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
la france doit mettre les bouchées
doubles pour que les handicapés puissent
bouger travailler ou aller à l'école
aussi nous suivrons la famille tan leur
fils est autiste la famille passent
chaque jour la frontière et la belgique
et pour cause le pays est en pointe en
matière de prise en charge des
handicapés mais avant direction
l'allemagne le première élève de la
classe se fait tancer par la commission
européenne pourquoi en économie
l'allemagne exporte rétro et
n'apporterait pas assez
c'est officiel une enquête est ouverte
contre le meilleur élève de la zone euro
l'allemagne soupçonnée de réaliser ces
énormes excédents commerciaux au
détriment de ses partenaires dans les
semaines qui viennent
berlin va littéralement être assailli de
questions par bruxelles sur ses choix
économiques
la commission européenne ne reproche pas
à l'allemagne d'être le numéro un en
europe même si cela risque d'être
compris comme cela outre rhin ce qui
inquiète bruxelles c'est que l'économie
allemande est unijambiste
elle ne repose que sur ses exportations
en économie y'a pas de secret les
excédents des uns font les déficits des
autres
on entend déjà les reproches de la
commission européenne allemagne fait que
tu aies citoyens consomment allemagne
dépensent plus
allemagne refaite et autoroutes sont
dans un état lamentable
l'allemagne va-t-elle obéi saura-t-elle
punis
la réponse c'est deux fois non non parce
qu'on ne change pas un modèle qui gagne
et non parce qu'on publie jamais le
meilleur élève de la classe
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par andreas schwab bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés allemands membres de la
cd où le parti d'angela merkel c'est
aussi un membre influent du parlement
européen où fait figure de pilier de la
coopération franco allemande
alors question tout ça vous voulez voir
ce petit reportage en tant qu'allemand
comment vous réagissez
parce que la commission pense le bon
élève allemand noms manquants jeu quand
je vis le petit film j'ai pensé que
c'était une bonne claque gars quand même
la commission européenne ne veut pas
reproché à l'allemagne est la force la
compétitivité mais avait plutôt faire en
sorte que à long terme le marché unique
fonctionne à un niveau vraiment égales
entre les états membres hésite à l'enjeu
principal aussi au parlement européen on
est d'accord là dessus ce que reproche
la commission c'est que l'allemagne
serait serait l'unijambiste elle l'ex
porterait trop elle partagerait pas trop
la croissance la la la demande
intérieure serait trop faible
c'est ça qui est un peu reproché mais là
il faut remettre un peu dans l'ordre les
choses alors l'excédent commercial
allemand a baissé dans les dernières
années de 5% à 2,2 quelque chose comme
ça donc c'est déjà en forte baisse et ce
que nous voyons en ce moment là c'est
une excédent des crédits un excédent
d'investissement car les allemands
apparemment préfère d'investir dans
d'autres pays en europe et très
déprimant des allemands ça c'est une
bonne chose il faut à long terme trouver
le bon équilibre et c'est un enjeu non
seulement pour l'europe et aussi pour
l'allemagne donc il faut pas confondre
les choses mais c'est toujours aussi
bien comprendre quelque chose vous
propose d'écouter elisabeth guigou à
l'ancien ministre des affaires
européennes elle est actuellement
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée nationale
elle explique pourquoi la commission
européenne a peu de temps ce critique
l'allemagne
écoutez on réussit vous régime juste
après
il s'agit donc pas de dire à l'allemagne
exporté moi il s'agit de leur dire
importer davantage c'est à dire
consommer davantage et investissez
davantage c'est vrai que la faiblesse de
la demande intérieure allemande est un
problème pour toute l'europe parce que
ça si ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
que la matière la croissance de
l'ensemble de l'europe et elle peut le
faire avec notre champ social vertueux
qui serait de soutenir ça consomme la
consommation chez elle et
l'investissement pour que la croissance
au monde ayant même temps pour que
d'autres pays européens en bénéficier et
à leur tour achètent davantage à
l'allemagne voyez donc s'agit pas de
dire haro sur les exportations
allemandes tant mieux ils sont très
performants
encore faut-il que leur prospérité
bénéficier aussi au reste de l'europe
parce que nous sommes tous un même
équipe
est ce que l'allemagne refuse de
partager avec ses camarades non on est
on est conscient du fait qu'on est dans
une équipe et heroes on veut jouer
ensemble mais en allemagne comme vous le
savez probablement les salariés les
salaires sont faites à travers des
discussions entre les entrepreneurs et
les salariés et les syndicats
et donc c'est pas facile de leur dire
écoutez il faut maintenant augmenter
comme ça comme ça c'est un débat qui se
fait de manière indépendante du
gouvernement
et deuxièmement l'investissement en
allemagne c'est vrai le la grande
coalition est en train de discuter sur
des plans de faire ça de relancer un peu
même les investissements mais les
autoroutes en allemagne comme on l'a vu
dans le petit film sont dans un meilleur
état
donc ça va pas aller si vite pour
augmenter la demande et le commissaire
européen aux affaires économiques olli
rehn dit il faut réduire le goulet
d'étranglement de la commission
intérieur diminue les impôts des plus
modestes accroître les investissements
publics et privés améliorer la
concurrence dans les services
la vice présidente de la commission
viviane reading dit qu'en allemagne les
infrastructures sont défaillantes on a
vu se disent pas un investissement pas
assez dans l'éducation et dans la
recherche ce que c'est pas des pistes
alors c'est des pistes fausse de mon
point de vue il faut c'est le point le
plus important redonner de la confiance
aux allemands car la crise euro même si
on lit crois pas a aussi fait peur à
beaucoup des allemands et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ne veulent pas investir dans la
mesure où ça serait nécessaire pour le
marché européen ça c'est le plus
important pour l'allemagne après vous
avez raison on va relancer les
infrastructures on le fait de d'un
moment à l'autre
la grande coalition veut faire un
nouveau point là dessus mais pour les
salaires ça sera plus difficile même
avec le smic est en train de se de se
faire dans une forme ou une autre
à la fin ça reste avec les syndicats et
les entrepreneurs de finaliser les plans
pour les salaires et si c'étaient les
autres qui avaient toujours on peut se
demander sur les français ou les
américains qui est qui et qui ont qui
ont tous fous les allemands il ya des
nouveaux pays les allemands leur vendent
des produits les équipes pour qu'ils
travaillent aux français d'en faire
autant pour le donner ce conseil
je pense il faut pas plus de conseils on
en a déjà assez
le but est clair nous devons être encore
plus favorables pour un marché intégré
par car beaucoup des produits qui
viennent de l'allemagne sont prêts pour
préparer dans les pays de l'est en
france ou n'importe où en europe
donc nous sommes déjà beaucoup plus un
marché qu'on ne le pense et c'est pour
ça que les chiffres que la commission
européenne utilise quelques fois ci des
chiffres encore nationale et les
chiffres nationales reflètent pas la
réalité en europe
donc je pense qu'il faut voir économique
les excédents des uns font les déficits
des autres
c'est une loi à wim et envoûtant en
france vous avez ça aussi entre paris et
lyon c'est pas à balancer
donc vous ne faites pas une statistique
pour la peau parier pour lyon donc la
statistique en europe elle est encore
nationale mais quand même
faut-il je pense faire en sorte que nous
arrivons à un meilleur équilibre pour
les investissements mais en étant c'est
très dur elle va avoir des conséquences
en allemagne non mais en avons discuté
la grande coalition veut lancer des
mesures mais ça va prendre du temps ça
va pas aller tout de suite
merci andrea schoepp d'avoir accepté des
invitations maintenant place place au
portage beaucoup de progrès d'ouverture
ont été faits en france pour améliorer
la vie des handicapés ces dernières
années mais à voir nos voisins il reste
beaucoup beaucoup à faire du coût des
parents d'enfants handicapés cherche des
solutions pour cela risée leurs enfants
par exemple ils vont de l'autre côté de
la frontière l'exil des français des
français handicapés en belgique c'est un
reportage de radical
allez taper allez zou le jour vient à
peine de se lever un run et ses parents
sont déjà en route pour aller à l'école
située à 60 km de leur village de le
quesnoy dans le nord de la france selena
et david en ont la certitude l'avenir de
leur fils est au bout de cette autoroute
de l'autre côté de la frontière
française là c'est la belgique
je passe la frontière quatre fois dans
la journée je préfère sacrifier mon gas
oil et ma fatigue et que mon fils puisse
aller à l'école comme à n'importe quel
enfant aller à l'école pour aaron était
encore inimaginable il y a quelques mois
il est autiste et n'a pas eu de place
dans une structure adaptée en france eva
ou la menthe au mantra est en bois et
vala super ses parents l'ont inscrit au
clair logis une école située à havré au
sud de la belgique
ici il est pris en charge toute la
journée par des professionnels bonjour
aaron depuis qu'il est arrivé dans cette
école
aaron a fait des progrès spectaculaires
il y a encore deux mois le petit garçon
était muré dans son silence et ne
prononcez pas une syllabe orange au les
instituteurs sont formées à la méthode
d'apprentissage kitsch une méthode
développée pour les autistes dans les
années 70 aux etats unis
le travail est individualisé et met
l'accent sur la mémoire visuelle dans
cette classe chaque enfant se repère par
sa couleur
le set de table orange s'est créé
c'est qu'il a très bien
fecteau à chaque classe est encadré par
une institutrice et une puéricultrice
pour un maximum de huit élèves
des effectifs très réduits mais
nécessaire les enfants autistes sont
imprévisibles
alors on s'assoit des crises comme celle
ci les autistes en font souvent ici ils
apprennent petit à petit à les surmonter
allons préparer très bien et en dro des
crêpes pour ses enfants communiqué
demande un effort de tous les instants
alors les maîtresses multiplie les
activités et les sorties scolaires pour
les ouvrir au monde extérieur et un peu
fait d'ailleurs écho l'extérieur ça peut
paraître jeudi
effrayant donc que le canaliser alors
que c'était travail je veux dire à
prendre aaron n'est pas le seul français
ce matin tous les élèves de sa classe le
son et cela n'a rien d'exceptionnel au
clair logis plus de la moitié des élèves
viennent de l'hexagone
chaque mois la directrice de cet
établissement public reçoit des dizaines
de demandes d'inscription venus de
france
de plus en plus je reçois de parents
français qui sont désespérés qui ne
trouvent pas de solution pour leur
enfant en france donc hier encore dans
mon bureau une maman et un papa qui
venait de franche comté qui avait fait
six heures de route parce que parce
qu'il ne trouvait pas de solutions chez
eux et qui est qui était très ému de
pouvoir trouver de solution ici en fait
à un enseignement qui puisse accueillir
leur fils
toute la journée comme aaron trois mille
deux cents enfants handicapés sont
scolarisés en belgique il y a encore
quatre mois le couple vivait à 800 km de
là près de bordeaux pour offrir une
scolarité adaptée aux besoins de leur
fils ils ont
quitter leur maison leur famille et
leurs amis la france très en retard sur
le traitement des autistes ne leur
proposait que des solutions inadaptées
on en propose soit l'hôpital les gens
donc prononcé en hôpital psychiatrique
deuxième solution c'était de mettre dans
une école aussi avec des maîtresses ou
des maîtres qui ne sont pas formés à
l'handicap à 7 ans n'écarte pas et nous
ça nous a fait peur donc cinq enfants
d'un coup pour un enfant qui ne
supportent pas la présence d'un enfant
n'hésitez pas poussé alors selena a dû
quitter son travail pour se consacrer
entièrement à l'éducation de son fils
pour le stimuler le couple dépensé plus
de 500 euros par mois en séances de
psychomotricité ou encore en
kinésithérapie un parcours du combattant
jusqu'à ce qu'il décide de se tourner
vers la belgique avec une structure
comme ça dallas ou d'invité banon serait
toujours là marc moi j'aurai retrouvé
mon activité professionnelle et on
aurait été gérant normaux faute d'une
politique volontariste en france le pays
voit un flot de parents français arrivés
livrés à eux mêmes
et là c'est de tourner en rond mais pour
combien de temps encore
certaines écoles belges arrivent à
saturation et la france ne semble pas
encore prête à changer de politique
voilà c'était un reportage de rabbi cas
et parce que souvent ce sont ceux qui le
vivent qui en parlent le mieux
jean-pierre riglaire est avec nous
bonjour vous êtes président de
l'association nationale coordination
handicap et autonomie dans le but de
soutenir des personnes handicapées en
recherche d'autonomie
vous êtes vous-même non voyant à vos
côtés jean-louis cottigny bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes pendant vos
mandants vous vouliez mettre votre
empreinte sur quelque chose ce quelque
chose ce sont les enfants et les adultes
handicapés ou alors vous venez de voir
le reportage de doha bika
l'établissement en belgique et publics
pour qu'en france il n'y a pas ce genre
d'établissement pourquoi l'éducation
nationale ne prend pas en charge ces
enfants
ce qui est inadmissible en france c'est
que les départements notamment puisqu'on
à la frontière de la belgique
le département du nord et du
pas-de-calais finances pour que les
enfants elle du nord je précise tout à
fait les conseils généraux du nord et du
pas-de-calais finances quand les enfants
vont danser d'établissements spécialisés
en belgique
pourquoi ne pas en construire par ici en
france j'ai eu le cas dans ma commune
j'ai eu une enfant handicapée que
l'éducation nationale ne voulait pas
parce qu'il fallait qu'elle soit
accompagnée par une personne
supplémentaire
j'ai embauché quelqu'un pour accompagner
cet enfant et mais il fallait que je me
bats avec l'éducation nationale pour le
faire accepter
considérant que vis-à-vis d'une classe
d'enfants ordinaire il était difficile
d'avoir un enfant dans le handicap c'est
dément il faut apprendre à vivre
ensemble
si on veut qu'à l'état d'adultes les
adultes accepte le handicap
ben il faut peut-être que le plus jeune
âge eh bien ils soient ensemble dans la
même classe je le crois profondément
c'est un manque de la france doit
combler joe perry glaire ccc france est
obligée de s'exiler en belgique
ça vous inspire quoi ça m'inspire que la
france a une culture déjà de
l'établissement spécialisé ces vieux de
trois siècles et demi ça remonte à louis
xiv c'est pas d'aujourd'hui ou
on a mis en place une politique de
l'enfermement c'est à dire mettre les
personnes différentes puisque à l'époque
on parlait pas de personnes handicapées
à l'abri des regards et des de la
noblesse et des bourgeois à paris parce
que ça dérange est déjà à l'époque
aujourd'hui ça dérange moins
heureusement mais le regard est
malheureusement n'a pas encore
suffisamment évolué et surtout la
culture c'est-à-dire de d'intégrer vous
dans votre association ou faire monter
des demandes de jeu par jeu par je
parlais à l'étranger l'autre côté de la
frontière parce qu'en france on on ne
s'occupe pas de moi vous avez ces
demandes là dans votre association non
pas directement parce que ça concerne
plutôt musclé entre autres les autistes
qui est un cas particulier mais je peux
vous citer le cadre d'une d'une personne
qui était membre de notre association et
qui a française qui vit en suède depuis
parce qu'elle a voulu profiter à l'âge
de sa retraite des avantages qu'offrait
la suède en matière d'accompagnement
humain elle y vit toujours
ça fait 14 ans et pour rien au monde à
lui viendra en france parce que même
après notre loi de 2005 dont on a
beaucoup parlé
l'accompagnement trop de la même peine
maximale et personne n'est pas encore ce
qu'elle devrait être
oui en france la scolarisation d'un
enfant
handicap est un droit mais pour ce faire
il faut être accompagné d'un auxiliaire
de vie scolaire
c'est là que le bât blesse il n'a pas
assez en français et si on a ils sont
mal payés leur rôle n'est pas reconnue
en fait par l'éducation nationale
oui et c'est pour ça en même temps que
les collectivités locales doivent être
aussi des partenaires de l'éducation
nationale pour accompagner dans la
différence ses enfants on ne peut pas
tout demander à l'état quand parfois les
collectivités eux-mêmes locales font des
dépenses qu'il pourrait peut-être
diminué pour être au service de l'être
humain
il y a plein de regard que l'on peut
avoir sur le sujet quand moi même j'ai
choisi dans ma ville de prendre un des
employés que nous avions formé pour
qu'ils puissent accompagner cet enfant
nous l'avons pris de la maternelle et
nous l'avons accompagné jusqu'au bac
elle est sortie première alors qu'à
l'époque on nous disait ne peut pas être
dans l'école donc je veux dire c'est
quoi la différence
la différence est d'être différent mais
apprenons à vivre ensemble et de nous
accompagner mutuellement
j'ai à prendre de monsieur qui non
voyants et j'ai lui j'ai à lui
transmettre ce que je vois alors andy
kapp légers ou lourds touche une
personne sur six dans l'union européenne
soit environ 81 millions de personnes
parmi elles beaucoup sont victimes de
discriminations quotidiennes
à leurs côtés des politiques nationales
très variables d'un état à l'autre
l'union européenne entend lutter contre
contre ces discriminations
elle fait quoi au juste c'est pour ça
que moi je me suis bagarré en devenant
parlementaires européens d'être dans la
commission des budgets et malgré que le
budget de l'europe que nous avons voté
hier pour le cadre pluriannuel et le
budget de l'année 2014
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je me bats
pour que malgré la la chute de 9% du
montant du budget que le ffs et le fonds
social européen n'est pas de diminution
quand je vois que des enfants du nord
pas de calais s'en vont pour être
accompagné en belgique
est ce que l'europe et le fonds social
européen dans cette europe que nous
voulons sociale elle ne doit pas jouer
un rôle pour mettre dans une manne
financière bien particulière
l'accompagnement de la différence je
pense que la france
le royaume-uni l'italie une grande
partie des fonds européens
social le fonds en direction du handicap
mais il faut l'amplifier
alors parmi ces discriminations vécues
par les personnes en situation de
handicap il ya la discrimination à
l'emploi regardez ce reportage
et vous réagissez juste après
tous les matins le même cérémonial un
petit café puis le taxi pour aller au
boulot françois gratte vol est
lourdement handicapé il ya 20 ans il
s'est brisé la colonne vertébrale
faisant du judo
je ne prends pas le risque de gros
perdant pas parce qu'il faut des
réflexes parce que c'est déjà très
spécial moins valides
si je peux éviter chez vite françois
arrive à son travail une société de
domiciliation d'entreprise salut exane
si françois réussi à conserver un emploi
malgré son handicap c'est loin d'être le
cas pour tout le monde avec la crise le
chômage des personnes handicapées a
bondi de 60% quatre ans les gens ont du
mal à bosser on le voit en france alors
qu'on est au paradis on voit la tête des
gens ni ça ne va pas au boulot en tout
cas et je pense qu'un handicapé peut
justement faire atterrir et rendre
remettre les choses à leur place et même
de l'humanité au sein de l'entreprise
mais l'humanité n'est semble-t-il pas un
argument assez convaincant pour les
entreprises le taux de chômage des
personnes handicapées reste deux fois
plus élevé que celui de l'ensemble de la
population
voilà on l'a entendu le taux de chômage
des personnes handicapées deux fois plus
élevé que celui de l'ensemble de la
population il ya un malaise jean pierre
angulaire
il ya un certain malaise et mais c'est
un vaste vaste problème une vaste
question
je voudrais pour être très précis deux
exemples qui sont très proches d'eux
très souvent les entrepreneurs vous dise
oui moi je veux bien embaucher mais je
ne trouve pas de personnes formées
suffisamment bien formés moi je connais
ici même dans ma ville d'hambourg à
strasbourg de jeune fille de 25 ans
elles ont bac +5 et au toutes les deux
sont au chômage
à la sortie de leurs études depuis plus
d'un an elles sont en situation de
handicap elles sont toutes les deux non
voyantes
pourquoi parce que et la réponse a été
claire pour l'une d'entre elles dans
tous les cas c'est quoi leur vécu elle
va demander du boulot et nouvelles vont
alors d'abord si vous demandez si vous
allez faire une demande d'emploi
ce n'est pas toujours la question est ce
que j'ai eu au téléphone je signale que
je suis non voyants ou non voyantes
alors il y en a qui préfèrent dire que
non et puis mais c'est reculer pour
mieux sauter parce que quand vous
arrivez à l'interview ils s'en rendent
compte et c'est la très souvent on vous
dit comme quand une personne dans le
temps arabes ou noirs vient des
discriminations c'est ça oui
l'appartement déjà occupé quoi mais on
vous dira on a déjà trouvé quelqu'un
pour l'emploi pour lequel vous postulez
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
effectivement un malaise et que les
entrepreneurs pensent toujours les
employeurs pensent toujours que
embaucher une personne handicapée ça
augmentera la charge de travail des
autres membres du personnel c'est un on
pense toujours que les personnes
handicapées même avec bac + 5
moi j'ai bac + 6 aussi on pense qu'il va
falloir les aider les assister il ya des
adaptations a bien affaire bien sûr
surtout ce qu'il faut c'est les mettre
dans le bon job et pas les mettre dans
un job où ils seront en difficulté à
jobs qui soit adapté leurs capacités
bien sûr mais aussi à leurs capacités
physiques ou intellectuelles et au nom
du droit au travail les états membres
ont obligation de tout faire pour qu'en
2020 les trois-quarts puisse avoir un
emploi pour cela il faut des formations
des lieux accessibles
on en est où monsieur continue c'est la
volonté de l'europe de faire un cadre de
façon à imposer à l'ensemble des états
les 28 qui est une possibilité
d'accompagner par le travail la
formation l'éducation ensemble de celles
et de ceux de nos citoyens européens qui
se trouvent dans le handicap temps
rappelant comme je viens de le dire
monsieur que le handicap est multiple il
ya le handicap mental qu'ils viennent à
la naissance ou un peu plus tard et a le
handicap physique est la naissance ou
ensuite comme on vient de le voir avec
le film ça n'empêche ça ça n'empêche pas
mais avant de bosser vous mais vous avez
vous avez recruté à l'assistance
oui mais apprécié augmenté après c'est
une volonté de chaque individu
après si tu ne travailles tu es mon
excellent la volonté et de chaque
individu puisque vous parlez du travail
de l'autisme c'est à dire qu' il n'était
pas reconnue n'est pas reconnue et le
nom de handicapés qui ne sont pas
reconnus parce que par la pauvreté de
certaines familles on n'a pas décelé des
maladies chez certains enfants qui en
grandissant se développe on en arrive à
une situation où n'étant pas reconnus
dans le handicap
ils sont considérés comme étant des
garçons qui ne sont pas formés qu'ils ne
peuvent pas tenir un poste de travail
est-ce que c'est pas le regard en fait
le regard de la société envers les cas
bien sûr monsieur voulait agir sur sur
l'autonomie c'est ça oui mais c'est pas
aux médecins de s'adapter c'est pas aux
auxiliaires s'adapter à la société de
chasse aux sociétés s'adapter et de
considérer la personne handicapée comme
un citoyen à part entière qui a des
particularités
auxquels la société bien sûr doit
s'adapter à travers une accessibilité la
plus large possible universelle la
contrôler et accessibilité sans concerne
pas uniquement les trottoirs ou les
transports c'est beaucoup plus large que
cela
c'est l'entreprise c'est l'ensemble des
établissements culturels
mais c'est aussi les biens et les
services et à ce moment-là toute
personne quelle qu'elle soit handicapé
ou non pourra bénéficier des offres de
la société dans laquelle il vit mais
c'est vrai vous le regard et surtout les
représentations qu'on a encore
aujourd'hui de la personne handicapée
qui est une personne diminué d'ailleurs
en espagnol on dit diminuée physique
pour les personnes handicapées ans et ça
veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire mais
assure que les personnes sont diminués
physiquement voire intellectuellement
intrasèquement parlant mais il ya
toujours des situations dans lesquelles
avec le bon accompagnement
elles peuvent trouver leur place dans
cette société et moi si j'avais un
message fort a passé et d'en profiter
très rapidement très rapidement ce que
ce sens et j'essaie de dire on sait de
dire qu' aucun être humain quelle que
soit sa place dans la hiérarchie sociale
ne peut dire qu'un jour il ne sera pas
lui handicapé ou qu'il n'aura pas un de
ses enfants ou petits enfants handicapés
je veux dire qu'à partir de ce moment là
soyons en capacité d'accompagner la
différence parce que la différence est
ce que ce ne serait pas nous merci en
tout cas messieurs d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin d'europe hebdo
bonne fête et programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
quoi